>>> BREAKING NEWS.
CNN JUST LEARNING BRIAN LAUNDRIE
AND HIS PARENTS STAYED TOGETHER
AT A CAMPGROUND 75 MILES FROM
THEIR HOME IN EARLY SEPTEMBER
RIGHT AFTER BRIAN RETURNED HOME
TO FLORIDA WITHOUT HIS FIANCEE,
GABBY PETITO, WHO, OF COURSE,
HAD BEEN LIVING WITH HIM THERE.
SO HE SHOWED UP WITH HER VAN BUT
WITHOUT HER.
IT COMES AS THE LAWYER FOR THE
PETITO FAMILY ACCUSES BRIAN'S
PARENTS OF NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
FIND THEIR MISSING SON.
LEYLA SANTIAGO IS OUTFRONT.
>> Reporter: AS THE FBI LEADS
THE SEARCH FOR BRIAN LAUNDRIE,
GABBY PETITO'S FAMILY SPEAKING
OUT.
STILL SEARCHING FOR ANSWERS AND
JUSTICE FOR THEIR GABBY.
>> THE LAUNDRIES DID NOT HELP US
FIND GABBY.
THEY SURE IS NOT GOING TO HELP
US FIND BRIAN.
FOR BRIAN, WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
TURN YOURSELF IN TO THE FBI OR
THE NEAREST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
>> Reporter: PETITO'S FIANCE,
BRIAN LAUNDRIE, WAS REPORTEDLY
LAST SEEN TWO WEEKS AGO TODAY.
POLICE SAY HIS PARENTS CLAIM HE
LEFT THE HOUSE WITH A BACKPACK
TO GO TO A NEARBY-NATURE
RESERVE.
THEY REPORTED HIM MISSING THREE
DAYS LATER.
THE LAUNDRIES RELEASING A
STATEMENT THROUGH THEIR ATTORNEY
MONDAY NIGHT DENYING THEY HELPED
THEIR SON GET AWAY.
SAYING, IN PART, CHRIS AND
ROBERTA DO NOT KNOW WHERE BRIAN
IS.
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BRIAN
AND HOPE THE FBI CAN LOCATE HIM.
THE SPECULATION BY THE PUBLIC
AND SOME IN THE PRESS THAT THE
PARENTS ASSISTED BRIAN IN
LEAVING THE FAMILY HOME OR IN
AVOIDING ARREST ON A WARRANT
THAT WAS ISSUED AFTER BRIAN HAD
ALREADY BEEN MISSING FOR SEVERAL
DAYS IS JUST WRONG.
IT COMES AS THE FAMILY ATTORNEY
TELLS CNN BRIAN LAUNDRIE WENT
CAMPING WITH HIS PARENTS AT THE
PARK FT. DESOTO SHORTLY AFTER
LAUNDRIE RETURNED TO FLORIDA AND
JUST DAYS BEFORE GABBY WAS
REPORTED MISSING.
ACCORDING TO PETITO'S INSTAGRAM
PAGE, THE COUPLE VISITED THE
SAME PARK BACK IN FEBRUARY
POSTING THESE IMAGES.
LOCAL OFFICIALS SAY THEY ARE NOT
ACTIVELY SEARCHING THE PARK, AND
A FORMER-PARK RANGER TELLS CNN
IT WOULD BE HARD TO STAY HIDDEN
THERE.
>> WITH TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY,
PROBABLY DAMN NEAR IMPOSSIBLE IN
THAT SMALL, LITTLE AREA.
>> Reporter: THE SEARCH FOR
LAUNDRIE INTENSIFYING.
THE MYSTERY, DEEPENING.
AFTER MORE THAN A WEEK OF THE
AUTHORITIES FOCUSING THEIR
SEARCH IN THE 25,000-ACRE NATURE
RESERVE NEAR THE LAUNDRIE'S
HOME, LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
SAY THE FBI OPERATION IS BEING
SCALED BACK AND TARGETED BASED
ON INTELLIGENCE.
ALL, WHILE GABBY'S FAMILY SHARES
WITH THE WORLD THEIR GRIEF.
>> ACTUALLY, GOT BEHIND A CAR
YESTERDAY AND THERE WAS A
WYOMING STICKER.
AND THE -- THE LETTERS WERE GBZ.
>> GABS.
>> Reporter: THE PARENTS AND
STEP PARENTS USING TATTOOS,
GABBY'S OWN DESIGNS, TO HONOR
THEIR DAUGHTER.
>> I WANTED TO HAVE HER WITH ME
ALL THE TIME.
>> Reporter: AND, YOU KNOW,
ERIN, YOU COULD REALLY GET A
SENSE OF THE STRUGGLE WITHIN THE
PETITO FAMILY TO MAKE SENSE OF
ALL OF THIS.
YOU HEARD THE DAD AT ONE POINT
SAYING DURING THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT THEY ARE JUST
TRYING TO FIND ANY WAY TO FIND
POSITIVE THINGS THAT CAN COME OF
THIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY TALKED
ABOUT IS THEY ARE HOPING TO
START A FOUNDATION IN HER NAME
THAT COULD HELP OTHERS WHO HAVE
DISAPPEARED.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, LEYLA.
>>> AND NOW, I WANT TO BRING IN
JIM CLEMENTE.
A RETIRED FBI PROFILER WHO HAS
BEEN ANALYZING THIS HORRIBLE
CASE FOR US FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
SO, JIM, UM, LOOK.
THIS IS KIND OF GETTING AT
SOMETHING YOU HAVE BEEN, I KNOW,
THINKING ABOUT AND CIRCLING
AROUND HERE FOR QUITE A WHILE.
AND THAT IS, THE -- THE -- THE
LAUNDRIE FAMILY.
AND NOW, WE ARE FINDING OUT THAT
BRIAN AND HIS FAMILY STAYED AT A
CAMPGROUND 75 MILES FROM THEIR
HOME AND THEY DO THIS AFTER HE
RETURNED TO FLORIDA WITHOUT HIS
FIANCEE WHO LIVED WITH THEM ALL
IN FLORIDA BUT WITH HER VAN.
AND HE COMES HOME AND -- AND
THEY ALL GO CAMPING TOGETHER.
WHAT QUESTIONS DOES THIS RAISE
FOR YOU?
>> WELL OBVIOUSLY, IF THIS IS A
CAMPGROUND THAT HE'S FAMILIAR
WITH, AND I BELIEVE GABBY AND HE
ALSO HAD LOOKED AT THAT
CAMPGROUND AT SOME TIME BEFORE,
THAT THIS COULD BE A PLACE THAT
HE MIGHT GO TO OR STAY AT TO
HIDE OUT.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING IS THE LAWYER'S
STATEMENT WAS THAT BRIAN AND HIS
FAMILY WENT TO THIS CAMPGROUND
AND HIS FAMILY LEFT TOGETHER.
I DON'T -- I DON'T KNOW WHY HE
WOULD DROP OUT BRIAN AND HIS
FAMILY LEFT TOGETHER UNLESS THAT
MAYBE WAS A PARTICULAR CHOICE
THAT HE MADE BUT HE DIDN'T SAY
THAT THEY ALL WENT BACK HOME
TOGETHER.
HE SAID THEY LEFT THE CAMPGROUND
SO I WOULD WONDER WHETHER OR NOT
HE DEPARTED FROM THEM SOMETIME
AFTER THEY LEFT THAT CAMPGROUND
JUST BASED ON THE STATEMENT THAT
THE LAWYER MADE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO -- AND -- AND, YOU KNOW,
AS -- AS YOU POINT OUT, RIGHT,
THE LAWYER HAS BEEN CHOOSING HIS
WORDS VERY CAREFULLY.
AND SO, IT IS IMPORTANT TO -- TO
THINK ABOUT IT THAT WAY.
SO THE LAUNDRIE FAMILY ATTORNEY
DENIED THAT BRIAN'S PARENTS HAVE
HELPED HIM EVADE ARREST.
AND IN A STATEMENT THAT SAYS IN
PART, QUOTE, CHRIS AND ROBERTA
LAUNDRIE DO NOT KNOW WHERE BRIAN
IS.
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BRIAN
AND HOPE THE FBI CAN LOCATE HIM.
OKAY.
SO THEY SAY THEY HOPE THE FBI
CAN LOCATE BRIAN.
NOW, HAVE -- HAVE YOU SEEN THE
LAUNDRIES ACT OR BEHAVE IN A WAY
THAT WOULD INDICATE THEY ARE --
THEY ARE FRANTICALLY LOOKING FOR
THEIR -- THEIR SON?
>> NO, I HAVEN'T.
IN FACT, I WOULD WONDER WHETHER
OR NOT -- I MEAN, THE ONLY WAY
THAT THAT COULD BE POSSIBLE IS
IF THEY ARE DOING THINGS BEHIND
THE SCENES WITH THE FBI BECAUSE
PUBLICLY THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE NOT APPEARING TO BE
INTERACTING WITH THE FBI AT ANY
TIME OTHER THAN WHEN THE FBI
KNOCKS ON THEIR DOOR WITH A
SEARCH WARRANT.
AND THIS IS VERY TROUBLING
BECAUSE IF THEY ACTUALLY WANT
THE FBI TO FIND THEIR SON, THEY
NEED TO ACTUALLY BE ACTIVE.
AND GIVING THEM ACCESS TO ALL
THEIR PHONES, ALL THEIR RECORDS,
ALL THEIR VEHICLES, AND ALL
THEIR FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
AND I JUST DON'T SEE THAT
HAPPENING AT THIS POINT.
>> SO, THERE -- THEY'RE -- IN
THE MEANTIME, THEY ARE FOCUSED,
OBVIOUSLY, ON THIS NATURE
RESERVE.
UM, AND I SPOKE WITH A RANCHER
WHO HAS WORKED NEAR THAT NATURE
RESERVE FOR 30 YEARS, RIGHT?
HE -- HE KNOWS IT LIKE THE BACK
OF HIS HAND AND THIS IS NOW, OF
COURSE, AS YOU KNOW, JIM, WHERE
POLICE HAVE BEEN SEARCHING FOR
BRIAN FOR THE PAST TEN-PLUS
DAYS.
SO I ASKED HIM, IS THERE ANY WAY
THAT BRIAN COULD -- COULD STILL
BE IN THERE?
UM, AND FOR -- ALIVE, FOR ONE --
AND HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD ME ABOUT
THAT.
>> THERE IS JUST NO POSSIBLE
WAY.
TO SURVIVE IN THERE WITH THE
MOSQUITOES AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND THE WETNESS, I MEAN, THERE'S
VERY FEW DRY SPOTS IN THERE.
THERE'S JUST -- THERE'S NO WAY.
>> SO, HE SAYS THAT -- THAT HE
COULDN'T BE IN THERE ALIVE.
HE ALSO TOLD ME HE DIDN'T THINK
HE COULD BE IN THERE DEAD
BECAUSE THERE HAD BEEN NO
BUZZARDS AND BECAUSE OF THE
WAY -- FIRST OF ALL, HE SAID
LARGE REPTILES WOULD -- WOULD GO
AWAY.
THEY WOULDN'T ATTACK.
BUT IF THAT HAD HAPPENED, THEY
THEN DRAG A BODY UNDERWATER
WHERE IT SITS FOR TEN DAYS
BEFORE THEY EAT IT.
OKAY.
SO I'M -- I'M BEING GRUESOME
HERE BUT HE IS MAKING THE CASE
FOR THEIR INFRARED WOULD HAVE
FOUND HIM, RIGHT?
SO, DEAD OR ALIVE, THEY WOULD
KNOW IF HE WAS THERE.
HE SAYS HE IS JUST NOT THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK, AS THE DAYS
PASS, THAT PROBABILITY IS
INCREASING THAT HE IS NOT THERE.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT -- THAT BRIAN LAUNDRIE IS
FAIRLY YOUNG, AND OBVIOUSLY USED
TO CAMPING OUT AND USING HIS OWN
SURVIVAL SKILLS.
>> YEAH.
>> NOT JUST, YOU KNOW, SORT OF A
WEEKEND CAMPER.
AND SO, HE MAY BE ABLE TO AVOID
DETECTION FOR A WHILE,
ESPECIALLY IF HE HAD A HEAD
START AND PLENTY OF SUPPLIES AND
HE HAD SURVIVAL GEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JIM, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ERIN.
>>> AND NEXT, WE ARE LEARNING
NEW DETAILS ABOUT WHY TRUMP TOOK
THAT SECRET TRIP TO WALTER REED
HOSPITAL, AND WHY HE KEPT IT
UNDER WRAPS FOR SO LONG.
>>> AND THE TRAGIC RESULTS OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT COVID.
ONE STATE REPORTING DEATHS
LINKED TO IVERMECTIN.
THAT'S THE DRUG COMMONLY USED
FOR LIVESTOCK.